[Music]
if tomorrow goes well we're gonna blow
up and that means we're gonna teach
music playing sold-out crowds after all
night sex and drug binges so we might as
well start to get used to believe it or
not that hard partying rebel on screen
is Austin Swift Taylor's 26 year old
brother he's now officially a leading
man starring in a dark and edgy drama
called cover version so you have starred
beside Pierce Brosnan and Ben Affleck
what did you learn from working with
those guys that you took into this role
I I think the biggest thing you learn is
just from seeing them work it's how good
they actually are and great they
actually are and you learn to aspire
higher than you thought you had to yeah
it's like they calls aspiring actors
like you aspire to be that good and that
capable and so tried to bring a little
bit of that to this one you're on set
with Debbie Ryan and this cast so what
does it like to be on set you guys had a
good time a little family it was awesome
it was you know most of the film was all
shot at the same location just kind of
showed up to work every day and made a
movie and hung out and had fun
Debbie's incredible she it was so fun to
work with her she's so knowledgeable she
did camera work everything it was it was
really great to use to work with her
movies in the future hopefully you know
did you get advice from Taylor to handle
this world a lot of advice in all
aspects but I think the best advice I
get from Taylor is that she says I can
do things that I can actually that you
know and in the sense that you know a
lot of times I'm more reserved
incautious and she's like you can do it
you can handle it
and that's always it's always nice to
have that in the background
[Music]
[Applause]